in recent years they had
appeared to grow closer but then came
the claims from
harry that his father and family
literally
cut him off financially when they
decided to step away from royal life
except now accounts show that prince
charles did continue to give the
sussexes money
a senior clarence house spokesperson
said the prince of wales allocated
a substantial sum to support them with
this transition
they added that funding ceased in the
summer of last year
the couple are now financially
independent
a spokesperson for the sussexes denied
there was a contradiction
saying the comments made during the
oprah interview were aligned with the
timeline that clarence house referenced
i wrote a piece in which i had spoken to
people close to prince of wales to
reflect
his surprise at the comments that harry
said he was financially cut off
the quote used for me was the prince was
very surprised to hear that he's seen
the bank statement
the palace accounts also include the 2.4
million pounds that harry and megan
paid back in relation to frogmore
cottage the huge cost to refurbish it
but the figures show the money hasn't
just been used to cover the
refurbishment
but also put towards their rent the
sussex spokesperson
said the duke has made a substantial
contribution to the sovereign grant
and all tenant obligations are being met
very much it was another
allegation from the sussexes that rocked
the royals this
year and for the first time the palace
have released their diversity figures
not a knee-jerk reaction to harry and
megan's claims they say but part of an
ongoing drive to do
more with 8.5 of their workforce
currently from ethnic minorities they
want that boosted to 10
by next year the accounts
show just how much covid has shaped
everything they've done
along with the family fallout it has
made it
a challenging year rhiannon mills
sky news